it is time for christmas
and with me at the desk best co-pilot in
the planet ross matthews hi everybody hi
we're celebrating nurses today and our
first story is about two nurses in love
okay so people magazine reports that two
er nurses in georgia got engaged on the
same hospital helipad where they first
fell in love
kelsey dunlap and jacob young met on the
job during the pandemic and for the big
proposal kelsey had no idea she heard
the helicopter had landed so she went up
with the stretcher
only to find jacob there with a ring
kelsey says that jacob is her best
friend and has been her biggest rock
through the toughest two years oh my
gosh
i know
he's been her biggest rock and given her
a rock i just i love this idea so much
that nurses could fall in love and again
like a little omg in the icu if you know
what i mean
it's like hey i see you looking at me
you want to practice some cpr
oh it's so cute right all right clap of
hands um who here has fallen in love at
work
[Applause]
i see some hand pointing
you are not moving and you have two
women literally going like this
right here
give it up tell us everything what
happened how did it happen
so
actually this is my wife monica oh
congratulations
okay how did you tell me when and where
um so i was a
nurse in the nicu and she started and we
had met previously through a mutual
friend and she started and
just
blossomed from there the rest is history
oh
and like what was the first thing
to your memory that made you think oh i
want to be around this person more
oh she's so infectious everybody loves
being around her she's loud she's funny
she's
cooks really well she's a great person
everyone here can vouch for that
um yeah and we we hit it off and we were
actually supposed to get married uh in
may of 2020 when coveted which so the
wedding got postponed so we just
actually got married in august oh
i love that
nurses are finding love and you know
there are some single nurses out there
and we got a story for you i saw
somebody yay in the audience single
nurses uh well healthcare workers you
guys know this that you have such
intense schedules it can make it hard to
date people and find people to date well
the site technically reports a new app
is changing all of that it's called
foreverx and it's a dating app
specifically for medical professionals
have you heard of this no okay well now
you have guess what
that's why we bring you the news yes
well it helps you make like-minded
people in your own field and it has a
special scheduling feature that allows
you to input all of your long shifts
and it will find the perfect time to
schedule a date with your perfect match
drew i see single nurses out here who
are like one more time what's it called
okay clap of hands who is very
interested in finding out about this new
app forever x clap yes they're clapping
i believe and i hope this is true if you
guys try this out that it can eradicate
the ridiculous time wasting back and
forth
windows everyone's got them can you make
it work or not do you know how much time
we can save
let me know
don't like when's the window how are you
no chit chat talk about a window we'll
get to know each other when we can that
is so romantic drew so romantic i don't
mean it that well you know what yeah
fine
i know i'm a romantic deep down in my
heart but where i lose interest is the
logistics that become impossible and
drive people apart yeah i am a romantic
just fit it in my window
[Laughter]
you're right that doesn't sound good i'm
just happy that this app exists stay
tuned they're gonna you're gonna use it
you're gonna use i see you guys let's
talk about it tell me how it works yeah
good luck keep us in the loop
all right next we've got a beautiful
story about one nurse showing up for her
fellow nurses as we all know nurses
spend hours you know there's hours with
masks on and it can cause a real strain
think about this on your ears if you're
wearing it all day long you all know
rashes blisters even cuts well surgical
nurse brittany diehan found some extra
time on her hands when surgeries were on
hold last year and she got busy sewing
it was a simple act she just added
buttons to headbands and handed them out
to nurses and that way she could attach
the strings of the mask to the buttons
look i'm wearing one right here it's
kind of cute hi look and there's buttons
the strings go on the buttons and not on
your ears how cute is that
and the nurses say it made a huge
difference in their day-to-day and
britney kept sewing and she shipped
masks to nurses in 49 states in the uk
canada australia
and now she's launched headbands for
heroes and you can buy a headband and
whenever you do one is donated to a
child undergoing cancer treatment this
is a phenomenal idea
um ross i just want you to say i just
want you to know that you do look like
um like you're in the karate kid or
cobra kai and i had panda i was going
for like norma desmond do you know me
like an old movie star but you were
giving me pat morita oh sorry and and
then karate kid like miyagi understood
so there was a slight communication
error you want norma desmond i give you
mr miyagi
um i love this i've never seen anything
like this yeah i have to say like i want
to i'm not a nurse i don't know if i
deserve to wear this but this is a real
game changer absolutely is and anybody
anybody who has to wear this for a long
time this is such a great idea this is
incredible well congratulations on doing
what you're doing
[Music]